uh why don't we get started
so um just just to get everybody where
where we are at um obviously we have
right now two bills two bills in
committee we have uh Senate Bill 98
and we have Senate Bill uh 85.
85 has been sent to us as a second
committee normally bills did we we're
not really a second committee but
um over the years it has um
has occurred
um and that and in this case in in
Senate Bill 85 there's a little section
in there
um that uh is is a
health insurance mandate and so
therefore um it it did cause it to come
to this committee uh so now we'll take
up the next issue is Senate bill 98.
um and
really
your phone is ringingly over here
okay all right sounds like it's coming
from
because I'm in The Matrix
okay so what I like to do is first just
um open the disc have the the motion and
then we'll have discussion so uh
representative patusek
uh second by representative that we
reconsider our action on Senate bill 98.
thank you Mr chairman okay um in as much
as I was the co-sponsor of the original
SB 98 with Senator Murphy uh and I voted
OTP
to move it forward I figured I might as
well be the one to move to reconsider
and so we can work on it move the
microphone closer
can you hear me can everybody hear me
because normally I speak louder I don't
know if I don't need the microphone
in as much as I was the co-sponsor with
Senator Murphy on the original SB 98
I figured it I might as well move it
forward for reconsideration and because
I the blurb was already written
so I hereby move to reconsider the
Senate bill 98.
okay so we're now open discussion
um so I want to First give a little
Prelude and then I am excited to hear
what everybody has to say all right
um that was saying that some people were
not supportive any marijuana legislation
no matter no matter what
um what occurs here is that yes we did
uh have um out of the blue
a second thought about uh the marijuana
legislation and even from the Senate
they did uh introduce a study committee
I don't know if all of you are aware of
this but they have introduced a study
committee
um that uh would review the issues of
creating a uh marijuana cannabis
statutes which would be operated by
um by the state
um I would say myself personally
um I was obviously aware of this issue
because we we did it last year senator
abbison now Senator I was where
representative was had uh had presented
the legislation and uh we had a fairly
Lively discussion on the house floor
um it did pass
um but then it failed in the Senate
um
I guess what I what I would say to you
is that the issue is is whether this is
something we want to get done
or whether we just wait
because I would also say that we have in
our possession now
as a retained Bill we have uh
representative Eaton's bill
and representative Eaton's bill is the
same bill it is operating by the state
so theoretically if we don't do this
reconsideration now
we would certainly uh come September we
will then dive in down deep into that
piece of legislation let alone the
Senate study committee doing whatever
they're going to do so we would have
something on you know theoretically we
could potentially have that issue on the
house floor
come next January
having said that
um what the key elements of this bill
and Eaton's Bill versus what we had
passed uh before is the idea of how many
locations we're going to have in the
state of New Hampshire
having said that it is that
I'm using that as the focus because
it is not in New Hampshire's way to
limit licenses
other states have done that and we we uh
we usually just we call it the taxi
medallion
that a city would only have so many taxi
medallions in its community and it would
restrict it what that does it creates
winners and losers because all of a
sudden now that taxi Medallion in and of
itself has value
and uh and we see in other states a a
liquor license is worth a quarter of a
million dollars
just in itself
so New Hampshire has never gone down
that path
and we've always taken the path that if
we're going to uh do something if we're
going to legalize it we're going to have
have stores whatever
um we're not going to limit how many
restaurants you can have I mean it's
amazing to me that some states will
literally limit how many restaurants
they have in a state
that we're not going to limit that we're
not going to we're we're you know or
we'll issue if we're going to issue a
license for it's come one come all as
long as you uh are have or find
outstanding citizens and don't have a of
a legal background that might bar you
from having a license
so
if if we could turn ourselves back to
when uh the prohibition ended and the
state of New Hampshire made a decision
to say okay we're going to have that
free-for-all with licenses when it comes
to beverages
and they set it at six percent but that
when it came to distilled including wine
that means over six percent
um the state made the decision to that
we they were going to limit access to
that those products and having to buy
through the state
in my mind after doing this being on
this committee so long what I think is
most interesting about that decision
what it is is that
when you go down that path you actually
don't have to set a tax rate
because the state is operating and
selling the product it has its margins
uh and then delivers that the margins to
the state so you're not you don't get
into the battles of tax rates which as
as anybody probably knows that once you
create a tax rate it can that's some
it's it can be fought over it can be
challenged it can legislature
can be annually questioning that tax
rate I would say in my time on this
committee the 30 cents a gallon on beer
has I've seen that bill at least to half
a dozen times
so
this model uh the appeal one of the
appeals of this models is that we don't
have to set a tax rate today if at some
point in time in the future we decide
that we do want to offered licenses that
the state New Hampshire might decide to
get out of the business and say that
doesn't want to do this anymore uh then
you know obviously
um at that point in time it fell off the
stores and and then set a tax rate but
if you do it this way then we're you
know you could say we're kicking the can
down but at this point we're saying is
uh that uh there was a other goal a
greater goal and that was that what we
have seen occurring in other states
is
uh I would call the the marijuana mile
in which you would have multiple stores
all in the same street up and down the
street and
um
I think that that is uh
the Senators is that is the most
offensive of the marijuana legislation
theoretically they're not all going to
stay open because the free market would
be at some point in time would
theoretically could uh fix that and if
they don't sell enough product and
they're going to go out of business
but that it it
is you know in terms of that possibility
or not where we are with that that if we
go with this model uh with that we just
go a limited amount of stores
we have the commission enforcement
division you know it has had obviously
this is the most way we can ensure that
young people are are not getting access
to marijuana through through the state
store State system
so having said that
um I guess I'll now be interested in in
questions that people might have on
whether we should reconsider yes
thank you Mr chairman uh way back when
at the uh
outset of your remarks I believe you
mentioned a house bill sponsored by
representative Eden correct that you
said was essentially the same as this
bill correct so are we are we then
really talking about a matter of timing
because the house bill which is re
retained yes
if it were to be approved
by this committee right it would hit the
event it would hit the floor in January
whereas this bill if would if we vote to
reconsider and then we vote to recommend
to the Full House and if the house were
to approve concur with the Senate
assuming there are no changes
the the effect would be more immediate
in terms of implementation yeah well
with respect to passage for passage yeah
exactly because to get this actually in
place so it's going to take a couple
years anyways okay thank you and one
follow-up question if I may for you so
would you uh just speak once again to
the the the the matter of a study
committee with respect to this
particular legislation and how the two
relate
so the study committee's report would be
at the end of good so it too
theoretically could have legislation
ready for January
because what the study committees the
study committee is is uh the report of
the study committee is supposed to be in
the end of November and in which then uh
that it would be in time for legislation
to be introduced in January
of everyone in me but we're really doing
it being asked to go along the creation
of the supplement request from the
Senate study and make recommendations of
implementation and and move the clock up
yes
representative Burrows
um has it been established who would be
on this committee would it be bipartisan
so the senate committee yeah uh it's it
has a fair amount of people on it
it's it's a commission so it's got a lot
of a lot of people but I think there's
four reps if I remember correctly is it
bipartisan
uh well
I'm not hearing an answer so the answer
is all committees are always bipartisan
so yes the four would be there would be
two Republicans and two Democrats
uh yes uh chairman hunt I wonder if you
saw this uh letter from uh marijuana
policy project that came in after seven
o'clock last night from Karen O'Keefe
um she makes some very interesting
points here that uh could throw sort of
a monkey wrench into this so basically
what she says is that
um a a state could have private
employees uh do something that might be
against federal law but they couldn't
have public employees doing that so it
throws up a roadblock if in fact The
Liquor Commission decided to
to uh sell it it's just a possibility
that somebody could file a lawsuit
against that and she recommends a couple
of safety valves to uh to overcome that
in case that's the case so I have to
admit I have not seen it so what were
the safety valves I'm sorry well we're
the safety valves the safety valve was
to offer an out to the state that they
wouldn't have to uh sell it themselves
and look can I get Carrie to make copies
of this and hand it out sure
I I thought you said we all got an email
to us
okay yeah I I have not seen it
but okay next is representative speaker
if I understand correctly
we are going to maybe vote on our on
this bill so uh the modification to 98.
and that would take precedence over what
the Senate is doing or it would it could
move things along faster the Senate the
Senate uh on another bill so we would
theoretically I I have to admit I'm not
sure whether the other bill was a
Commerce Bill does anybody know whether
what was the number what what committee
was it in
yeah
help so theoretically we we uh we would
have to have the health committee we
would talk to the chair and ask him uh
you know to whether to uh
to whether we support the idea of that
study committee and then and then we
usually normally if it does go to
committee conference we get one seat uh
at the table for that and but in that
yes that would be done through Community
Conference Then I then I have this
question
this bill or 639 the original bill which
this is a very small modification of
right
was studied extensively by both parties
a huge amount of effort was put into
creating that bill correct it was
bipartisan in nature both teams agreed
to it right and it was
told by a lot of a number of people that
came here in the hearing said it was
pretty good
so my question is how much more studying
are we going to do on this you can study
this until we all die of old age
which is getting very close I mean what
are they going to find that's different
that we don't already know right
right uh I would yeah um
obviously there are
um certain Senators who are reluctant to
pass it and they were able to convince
other Senators to go with the study
committee
uh we we do not presume other people's
motives
okay
representative Herbert
so yes if we don't reconsider this uh
98 if we just say no then 98 we'll just
go on with the uh
um the motion that we already have
passed in passing 98 and at that point
the only thing we would have left is we
have uh representative Eaton's bill that
we would be able to work on
um this year and then introduce on the
floor come January
would you believe
yeah
make sure your microphone is on and and
you speak closely so we all so everybody
at home can hear you
uh would you believe it's my in my
opinion that it's we're at a place that
we can pass this legislation as is
uh and that I think the State Liquor
Commission is the right place to do so
when we as we did with liquor
and uh from my point of view would you
believe I don't want to do anything more
than what we've already done I just want
to pass the legislation this amendment
yes no no this is to reconsider no no
we're reconsidering Senate Bill 98 was
all it was uh was that we were changing
the dollar amount of when a someone has
not paid the bill to their beer
distributor from a hundred dollars to
250. so once we reconsider that then
it'll be open for a new Amendment and
that's what we hope to take up at 10 30
if we have a prevailing motion now on
the reconsideration motion
no no I'm even more confused
we need to open this up so we can add
this amendment to it and the amendment
is this is an amendment this is a
non-germaine Amendment
this is a non-germaine Amendment and it
can't be introduced to regas we right
now we have no more liquor bills left in
the committee
okay so this bill we still have because
we did pass it it just didn't get sent
over
fortuitously and so we have it available
so if we vote if you vote now for yes to
reconsider
vote now yes then we can take up 98
we're not going to vote on the 98 today
okay because we want to go through
normal Commerce process which is a
subcommittee and make sure that that
we've got all our eyes dotted and T's
crossed and then next week we can then
vote Senate Bill 98 that will have the
underlying language that was already in
the bill it'll have this new Amendment
and we would be sending that to the
house floor with this new amendment that
has the Liquor Commission operating in
the stores
so the Liquor Commission was not in this
original
again this amendment is uh mirrored off
of a
uh we we passed 639 but 639 was
different so this is a new Amendment
this is totally a new Amendment to the
extent that we the concept of having the
Liquor Commission run the stores rather
than free enterprise you know having
private businesses run it okay I must
have been I must have misunderstood the
previous conversations because I all
along have
wanted and agreed to and I thought it
was already here that the Liquor
Commission was going to be as they do
with liquor would be the uh operators
that was that was that was
representative Eaton's bill and yes now
that is back it has risen from the dead
it's right here in front of us but you
have to first vote Yes on the
reconsideration of Senate Bill 98 so
that we can take that up
thank you okay
Representatives
you knew that I was gonna well I didn't
think you would let this go
I just wanted to mention how much I
vehemently disagree with some of my
colleagues here that there will never be
a good time to legalize
more drugs into New Hampshire
and expose our children and expose towns
to them that might not want it if it's
in a liquor store in their town they
would be able to veto it okay they would
in this bill is that that the accounts
would absolutely
a lot of positive uh from the municipal
Association that the language that we
that we chose in here they're very very
happy with in terms of community control
over whether one of these things would
open up in their town
but go on
well some of us as you know will never
be happy with legalizing
marijuana cannabis whatever you want to
call it uh in New Hampshire whatsoever
so you know I I hope to represent all of
those people and always be a hard no
just be on the record for that and we
appreciate that I really do
okay any other discussion on the motion
to reconsider Senate bill 98. yes
representative Gibbs uh thank you Mr
Sharon uh I just want to say that I
support uh reconsidering Senate Bill 98
because I think that this amendment is
important as I understand it under
current law even though marijuana has
been decriminalized people are still
being arrested and getting criminal
records for it uh and state resources
are being in my opinion wasted pursuing
those cases and I want to see that
stopped
fair enough any more discussion on the
motion okay the uh Clerk
will call the roll on reconsideration of
Senate bill 98.
foreign
yes
representative Osborne yeah
representative petusic yes Terry
no
post
nope
Cole no
jelly
no
Paxton yes
Walsh no
Burrows yes
pervert yes
follow you
no
we're clear not clear yes
Vincent
yes
collabro
no
no it's not here Gibbs yes
spear yes
so
and
chairman hunt yes
six seven eight eleven eleven one two
three four five to seven eleven seven
okay
great uh the motion passes and we will
end our executive session
right we recommended people take a look
at this right now we got five minutes or
so yeah yes time to read
oh
Finance
let's see
okay
dude
all right
okay okay so uh we'll start opening up
the public hearing on the non-germain
amendment
um I would ask if anybody has written
testimony we'd we'd love if you could
submit it to the clerk so uh she can uh
relax and not be too stressed over it
okay
well I have one representative card uh
representative almie
and she doesn't
come on up yeah
so basically the the purpose of this
public hearing is to
find out
how people feel about this amendment and
pros and cons and uh about this
amendment
so good morning morning uh
representative Susan Almy on city of
Lebanon
from ways and means but on
I've only talked a little bit with a
couple of the people in ways in Maine
since I learned this was happening which
yeah I learned this was happening just
two and a half days ago I think it is
um
and got
the bill on
I understand you're going to have a work
session which is good because I think
you're going to need a lot of amendments
after this
uh
their
are particularly well on Page Six
on you've got one small errata
line 28
265 A1 is a list of definitions
not
six I'm I didn't see definition
uh page six okay
uh
there's a on a person may not be
convicted of both a violation of this
section and a violation of RSA 265 A1
that is a list of definitions
it is not anything that is a violation
Okay so
okay good pickup that's one the other
one's more
related to what we do in ways and means
on
the line 11 on page 21 when when you're
establishing the Cannabis fund
um
it is not 17 million 500.
on yeah we do have a new amendment to
change those dollar amounts changes that
to 15 million and not to the 500 because
the 500 is in paragraph Roman Roman 4.
so and
representative Ames read this quickly
last night uh
and
there you do we do have Appropriations
in two places
and they look somewhat different he
added them all together and said why are
they giving 31 million
to this
um
and
I am not sure I haven't had time yet to
talk with the drafting people but I'm
not sure we had this problem in our
committee too and we left the double in
but the double was easier to connect at
that point
um
maybe it's sufficient to just change
this to 15 million
or on
in the flow of what you're doing you
probably need it here but we also made
sure we had it in the back so that
people would see the Appropriations
so that's just something I guess so it
is true that uh giving the the model the
business model
that now the state is has a bigger cost
to the state to operate these stores
that it didn't have before so there will
be some changes in the appropriation
amounts
more than this yeah okay so that's
another problem that I really got I read
through this I read through it very
carefully except for the criminal parts
and on I came to the conclusion that you
were
that the Liquor Commission was going to
uh
license retailers that was the old Bill
yes that was 16. yeah I know that was
that was the old Bill correct and that
there was no tax
so there was no Revenue yeah uh
representative Ames last night came to
the conclusion that you decided that you
were running the retail stores but I
guess Contracting some employees that
were going to run them
there's a possibility that could occur
but that is not that is not you know I
mean at this point in time it will be uh
that that hasn't been determined that
the commission has to work through that
but yes we are the the concept the
business model is that we will not have
a tax per se because the state will be
operating the stores and what that
requires is that the Liquor Commission
figure out what to pay the farmers and
what to charge the retailers I mean what
the retailers should charge
uh
for for the marijuana well they are the
retailer they are the retailers they are
the retailers with um with employees in
those stores correct
on
so in terms of how much the how much
they're paying the cultivators that
would be negotiated price between the
cultivators and the commission
the cultivators do not have
much say except to not cultivate in that
position I think
that's true they could decide that they
don't think it's worth worth you know
coming in but I would venture to say
that if I were a cultivator I would not
be negotiating with the commission until
uh I would not be beginning construction
I would not be doing anything unless I
knew I had a contract with the
commission once they produce the product
or what what the how much money I was
getting for I bet you even the banks
would require that yeah and um
the problem with this is if you're
allowing people to grow
on on
on Real Farms
and they are producing a different level
type of marijuana they have a great deal
more risk than the people who are
growing it in the in the big
um big manufacturing plants let's call
them uh the big manufacturing plants are
the best way to guarantee that you've
got high quality Maryland marijuana
cannabis uh well little I know I would
venture to say that no one will be
growing marijuana out in the fresh air
because New Hampshire doesn't have a
very long growing season I would I can
almost assure you that the only
marijuana that you're ever going to see
cultivate in the state is going to be
Factor you know within a side of a
closed building in a controlled
environment and there are there was one
farmer that came to our
hearing okay and insisted that he had
been growing hemp for some time under
the under the federal
law and that he really wanted to grow
marijuana and he could do it because he
already knew how to do it under the
federal law
um
I would be much happier if this Bill
said it can't be grown Outdoors except
in a a particular kind of greenhouse
because otherwise there are a number of
people I think that want to try this um
even though the Farm Bureau doesn't have
any interest
that feels a little micromanaging at
this point to decide how they're going
to grow it and where they're going to
grow it well the question is who who
would who is the Liquor Commission going
to negotiate with about these prices
to cultivators
all of them
including this guy wants to grow it
outside and the people who who think
they could grow it in greenhouses
it's what they do with liquor now
no they don't don't negotiate they buy
wine in bottles
and they're they have access to a lot of
national information about how wine is
sold everywhere and which wines are not
doing well this year I know that because
of wine I really liked disappeared
okay all right anything else
um
so um
so then then there's also a question
about
uh there are we now and this was in the
previous Bill we've got
we're setting up a new fund on page 25.
uh oh no that's the old fund we have the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund already
and on page 22 we are setting up the new
on
fund
shoot did I get this in the wrong place
A Substance Abuse Prevention and
Recovery Fund online 18.
um
they both sound like they're being doing
pretty similar things this one does not
have a 612 reference yet needs one
uh
speaking as a dedicated fund person
and
but
it seemed I guess that because of the
federal considerations we have to keep
it separate from the other fund
but there ought to be some kind of
interaction I guess that you're going to
leave a lot of this to the
The Liquor Commission to try to figure
out
absolutely
so great any questions from the
committee members
seeing your oh maybe you're not done
no I yeah I'm I'm done I think that
oh you have multiple uh I suggest
someone do a search of the word tax yeah
I did notice I fix everything yeah we
will be removing all the word taxes and
make it a little bit clearer that we're
going to end up with a liquor store
correct liquor store model yes thank you
thank you okay uh next I'll call in
Michael Holt who's from the Department
of Health and Human Services who
oversees the therapeutic
atcs
great
clerk appreciates it
there's a
uh good morning thank you my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services
um I've got a couple of uh handouts
going around
um one is a is a list of uh
um suggested edits and the other is a
copy of uh
um
Amendment
2023 1892 age which was the one that was
posted on the uh on the website
um and it only contains those uh pages
that have
um that have uh potent uh suggested
edits
um so thanks for the opportunity to
comment on this amendment um I'm not
going to cover the public health related
issues that have already been discussed
and rejected like a cannabis Advisory
Board which Public Health thinks is an
important feature for a legalization
effort
um uh annulments which is another
important social Equity provision in
cannabis legalization
um and I'm not going to cover issues
that have already been decided policy
wise like the preference for a free
market model over a state control model
um I did want to provide you a short
list of items for consideration for an
additional Amendment
um and the list includes typos language
changes for consistency and a few
substantive issues for uh for discussion
um
first off I'd like to say that from the
perspective of the state's therapeutic
cannabis program the state control model
proposed Works only because it allows
dual use licenses for atcs to
participate in retail sales of a
cannabis it's the only way this model
Works absent this allowance the
viability of the atcs to continue to
participate in the state's therapeutic
cannabis program would be severely
threatened
and the viability of the therapeutic
cannabis program in general would be in
Jeopardy so I want to thank you for
maintaining the allowance for atcs to
enter the retail sales Market as
proposed by this amendment
that being said the bill could be
clarified in a number of places
throughout the bill to make it more
explicit there appears to be some
conflicting Provisions that say oh all
retail sales will be conducted only at
State Stores but throughout the bill
there are uh the the references to allow
dual use certificates for retail sales
is maintained so
um again some clarity uh should be uh
should be exercised in the bill but
again maintaining the ability of the
atcs to enter this Market is critical
for the therapeutic cannabis program to
be maintained
um
from a public health perspective there
are three items on this list that I want
to emphasize the first being the most
important
um the first edit appears on page nine
of the of the handout
um you can see them all highlighted
should be easy to follow along
um but on page 19 uh the bill
establishes a serving size limit of 20
milligrams of THC per serving this is a
unreasonably high and unsafe serving
size amount it should be the statute
should should say five milligrams per
serving at most there's a provision in
this bill that allows the Liquor
Commission to change that amount through
rulemaking but the floor absolutely
should be five milligrams per serving
this is the most critical piece Public
Health Wise of this legislation that
needs to be changed
um the second issue I'd like to
highlight is on page 13 which proposes a
transfer or a plan to transfer the
therapeutic cannabis program from the
Department of Health and Human Services
to The Liquor Commission
um
there's no appetite for either agency to
have this transfer
um this bill would require a plan for
that within about two years
um I in my opinion this is a holdover
from previous uh versions of the bill
which established a a new cannabis uh
commission where that might be more
appropriate but under the current model
with the Liquor Commission
um it does not make uh policy sense
um from our perspective and probably
from Liquor's perspective as well uh to
consider a transfer of the medical
program over to uh the the the
commercial retail program
um so I'd urge that be removed as well
um uh the the third uh point I wanted to
raise on page 16 of the um of the
handout
um
yeah that's 15 and 16. there's a
requirement in the bill for cannabis
products to be dispensed in child
resistant Packaging
but there is no requirement for cannabis
to be dispensed in child resistant
packaging and because these terms are
Divine defined strictly
um in section one
um this uh this I believe this is an
oversight all cannabis flower and all
cannabis products uh should be dispensed
in child resistant Packaging
um so those are the those are the
highlights I don't want to take up tons
of your time but I I would urge you to
go through this list
um it's uh there's other issues uh typos
redundancies
um lack of clarity
um I guess one of the other I I can't
stop myself one of the other things is
um there's a there's a provision
throughout that allows
um
there are references to a municipality
uh limiting the number of licenses in
their Community however the new section
on municipalities and and the
requirement for them to take take a vote
does not seem to allow them to identify
the number of licenses in their uh in
their in their in their towns it's only
an up or a down yes we have them or no
we don't um there's also no provision
for uh towns and cities to choose which
types of facilities in the um uh in
their municipalities
um I'd also point out that there's a a
peer there appears to be a redundant
appropriation
um for the money coming to us uh HHS
um uh and money going to The Liquor
Commission one place that says eight
million the other place that says 17
million in two different sections of the
law so again all those are detailed in
the in the handout
um and I'm happy to you know answer
questions about this stuff now or later
um
thank you representative Cherry has a
question
uh thank you um given that this is the
house Commerce Committee and not Panera
is where I could pick two I'm going to
do a 1A and a 1V Mr chairman so I don't
have to ask for a follow-up and so here
we go
um were you involved with this bill as
it was drafted and ultimately passed in
in this senate committee and the and the
Senate as a whole and if so can you
explain how
we could Poss they could possibly have
inserted 20 milligrams rather than five
in view of the fact that you have
identified that as unsafe
um would they have had to be unaware of
this because you didn't give that input
or anybody else or can you can you
address that were you involved and if so
how do you explain 20 in this version of
the legislation
when it is unsafe as you say and and
should be five
I've been in I've been involved in the
development of this legislation since uh
the first public hearing on the bill
um the Senate did not introduce 20
milligrams 20 milligrams came out of the
house
got sent to the Senate
oh
so his question is why didn't you
question it then
when I was in the house when 639 in the
house we uh because an earlier version
of The Bill said
um five milligrams and in some setting
it was changed uh during executive
session and subcommittee work to 20.
excuse me
that's what he says I don't know
representative Burroughs I also had a
question on the dose you said that five
milligrams is a single serving my mom
was 411 and weighed all of 95 pounds
with that I'm just wondering if that
would have knocked her on our keister I
would have suggested that she start with
half that cut cutting it
half of five would it would that would
it be important to indicate that
somewhere on Packaging
there are requirements in the bill for
packaging and information packaging
information warning labels about the uh
the time to affect you know how long it
takes you know a product to uh to
achieve effect
um I believe there's sufficient
education requirements in the bill so
that
dosing is uh is an Education topic that
can be given to the public however
starting the floor at 20 milligrams will
absolutely have a profound impact and an
increase in accidental what we call
poisonings unintentional poisonings of
an overdose of cannabis thank you
thank you representative Philip
thank you for taking the question uh
continuing the theme Here of the the
serving size given that uh five
milligrams tends to be the standard
serving size would there any be any
reason to include administrative
allowance to change the serving size
amount or should it just be set as a
standard five milligrams and eliminate
the administrative allowance to a change
of serving size the administrative
allowance for increasing over five was
language that was added when there was a
cannabis Advisory Board in the bill and
the language uh proposed said
um with the approval or the the the the
in consultation with the Cannabis
Advisory board so the idea here was that
um if the Liquor Commission wanted to
increase it to say 10 that might be
reasonable other markets have a 10
milligram size
um uh and so we wanted to give the like
a commission a little bit of flexibility
but have that have a um have a have a
consultation requirement with public
health experts
um
so to answer your question
uh
one of the things need to change you
know five with no allowance to change or
five with an allowance to change
um if uh
if Liquor Commission were to change it
from five to twenty through rulemaking
there would be significant uh
involvement from Advocates about a uh
about such an increase
um so the question could you talked
about packaging
so uh with the atcs now do they uh the
package the marijuana in a form that
children can't open
yes all cannabis and cannabis products
uh packaged by the ATC has come in child
resistant so they already have that uh
including um child uh child resistant
reclosable child resistant containers
for multi-use items so given that atcs
are non-profit
this this bill would allow them for a
for-profit conversation I
the
the discussion is about the atcs and
that uh you made it clear that they have
to be included in the bill
um I I didn't read it that way frankly
um I read it that the Dual license was
so that they could be cannabis producers
but that I did see specifically a line
in the retail line that says only only
The Liquor Commission can sell it so
what what I'm asking you is you're
saying that it has to be in here they'll
go out of business are you saying that
that there's not enough medical buyers
as compared to what will happen in the
commission that the commission stores
and that the commission stores will be
lower price
than what the atcs are
yes interesting okay that this has been
our testimony since you know day one
when this spill was introduced along
with all the other um cannabis
legalization bills that are perspective
um is you know we need to the state
needs to maintain the viability the
therapeutic cannabis program
um and every state that has legalized on
cannabis thus far has been able to
maintain that program
um but one of the key pieces there
um for the the successful operation of a
medical program after legalization is
that legalization models have taxes and
high taxes so there is a there is a cost
benefit for patients
to go to the medical dispensaries and
purchase untaxed products
um each of these versions of the bill
makes the Cannabis cheaper and cheaper
um and the only way under this model
where the only retail sales are either
the state or the atcs the atcs need to
be able to enter this Market otherwise
they there will be they won't be able to
compete patients will go to where the
prices are low even though they're not
getting medical education even though
they're not getting the products that
they need like ratio products CBD THC
ratio products products like
suppositories that no recreational
dispense dispensary is going to sell why
wouldn't the states sell it why would
the state sell it well because they want
to
sell it because they're the one person
one entity that's been licensed in a
recreational store that has a
suppository as a product so that could
be what big difference about doing it
through the commission is that we would
actually be able to be doing things that
the that retail stores don't do that is
one very minor example illustrating the
larger point of
in order for this model to be viable the
atcs need to be included in retail sales
as the amendment proposes the definition
of dual use certificate on page four
specifically says that allows the atcs
to co-locate with and operate a retail
cannabis store the rulemaking provisions
on Dual use certificates include you
know it's it's a whole page on
requirements for retail sales clearly
the intention of this amendment well is
to include atcs and that sales okay
gotcha
all right representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chairman
um is it possible also that
um without the Dual license opportunity
uh that some of the atcs might uh lose
business because the therapeutic uh
cannabis buyers might just find it
simpler uh to go to the retail store
without going through the process of
getting approved for therapeutic
cannabis absolutely yes that happens
that is expected to happen with any
legalization model uh patients can go as
adults to uh uh to recreational uh
dispensaries and avoid talking to their
doctor avoid paying an administ an
application fee for the cannabis card
from us
um and to avoid being on a essentially
what is considered a stake list of uh of
of patients so yes absolutely that will
happen regardless
um so it is important to uh
incentivize people to maintain their
registration on the on the therapeutic
program
um and not self-medicate thank you
thank you very much
uh chair will call on Nathan Griffin
from the New Hampshire cannabis party he
was in support of the bill
oh sorry
push the button make sure you push the
red button
oh does that work now oh good yeah
um I have a little material just to hand
out in support of uh one of the points I
want to make okay
good morning Mr chair
um members of the committee thank you
thank you
thank you for the opportunity to uh
provide a little bit of hopefully
helpful information on this particular
bill
um generally speaking I would say that
this is a workable first uh prototype of
a cannabis legalization program from New
Hampshire uh it's not perfect it's got a
bunch of warts I think there's aspects
of it of um of policy that could be
improved but um it does appear
that um one of the features of this
amendment is that it does give a
significant amount of discretion over
the next couple of years
um to The Liquor Commission and
um my understanding and knowledge is
that they've actually put in a fair
amount of work in studying this industry
over the last year in particular they've
gotten up to speed
that they would be
committed to making this uh successful
both for the state in terms of Revenue
as well as the general pro lifting the
general prosperity of a lot of New
Hampshire residents and so I think that
that gives us the opportunity to
you know make this even more efficient
and productive than some of the
specifics within the bill so generally
speaking I would say that it's a it's a
pretty good initial start and I would be
in favor of with a couple of minor
harmonizing improvements
you know to recommend that this bill you
know pass and we get started on you know
a proper cannabis legalization program
in New Hampshire
um so the couple of points that I wanted
to make are um that there is some
obsolete language and a couple of things
um in here that could um could really
throw a bit of a monkey wrench into
really into implementation
some of which I think has been
highlighted by others but one thing that
is kind of important and this is related
to the handout that I sent out is that
um for up until about a year ago there
was a lot of confusion in the industry
and in government with regard to
cannabis seeds and hemp seeds
they nobody really had clarity as to
whether it was really cannabis and
whether it needed to be only sold let's
say Day by dispensaries and and licensed
operators or whether it was more like
hemp and given my own background in
cannabis Banking and payments and
financial services it was a very
bedeviling thing in in which to be
perfectly Frank um Bankers were more
comfortable
banking dispensaries and cultivators
than they were people who were selling
seeds because it was in such a gray area
however since the original language that
I think has um still kept been kept with
regard to seeds particularly um
saying that the seeds would have to be
um
uh you know made to not be able to
germinate and so on um the um DEA
um finally came out with
um clear
um guidance on this
um and um that's the material that I
sent out there's a an article from a
trade
publication that summarizes that as well
as the actual guidance letter that was
received by uh somebody who inquired of
the DEA and their basic conclusion was
that um cannabis products or cannabis
plant materials that are under the 0.3
percent THC by dry weight definition
that they have uh that the feds have
applied to hemp are considered hemp and
this was very clarifying um you know
especially from a banking and payments
point of view because now what was was
able to happen in fact our own
professional experience was that we were
able to get a lot of clarification and
Banks were now able to provide normal
financial services and banking to uh
folks who were producing and selling
seeds because now they could basically
treat it from a compliance point of view
as hemp
um so I would like to just call people's
attention to
it's a
well I don't it it's actually on page
three of the handout but it's basically
318-ft
um colon one definitions um Roman
numeral two there are um some references
to seeds sterilized seed of the plant
that is incapable of germination all
this is basically obsolete language and
I think that if we leave it in here it's
going to create some um uh
contradictions that can result in
confusion and
um and disputes that are entirely
unnecessary
um so I would um just urge you guys
um in the working session to kind of
just harmonize uh the you know the
current federal guidance and Regulatory
on cannabis seeds and hemp seeds to be
just included in the broad category of
hemp which is basically the way it's
treated by you know bankers and
financial service agencies and the
government at this point and and that
way
um uh you know if to whatever extent we
are and there is reference in here to
regulating
um you know hemp by the commission
um that uh see it can both cannabis
seeds and and hemp seeds be um just
considered to be um you know hemp
products and and regulated uh to
whatever extent they are on that kind of
basis
um the other thing is that um you know I
would like to say
that because there does seem to be
within this amendment a fair amount of
discretion
um that the Liquor Commission would have
in actually executing and operating uh
this um you know kind of hybrid State
model
um that um it would probably be a better
idea if we have any ambition of actually
getting this through uh in the next
three weeks before the end of the
legislative session
um that um any that we kind of limit any
amendments and corrections to um to just
kind of harmonize language make sure
things are are consistent and minimize
the number of tweaks and fixes even
though you know there are a number of
you know smaller and medium-sized things
that would probably be better to include
in the bill and the reason for that I
think is that um if we send too many
changes over to the Senate that you know
even if they may be um inclined to to
work through it uh you know they're not
really going to have time and and
so a lot of our efforts will really come
to naught this year so my recommendation
there would be that um we limit the
number of amendments and changes to
things that are you know kind of
grammatically or harmonizingly
um you know important and not give them
too much on their plate to have to
digest because they could run out the
clock there
um and you know to that point
um
you know one thing that I think that we
should have some concern about and that
is
um it's less of an issue it I I think
it's good public policy that we have
annulment or expungement of criminal
records for people who have um you know
had you know had uh
not large-scale uh cartel type dealers
but people who have had relatively small
brushes with the law with regard to
cannabis up to this point
um that that would be good public policy
but I don't think that it's absolutely
mandatory in an entire private
commercial
environment but I think one of the
problems that we're going to run into
and this could really derail this
entirely is to have the state engage in
activities and practices that let's say
you know six or twelve months before you
know people have you know paid um uh you
know legal prices and had consequences
and jail time and have a criminal record
or um or uh you know that that
contradiction could could result in
lawsuits and other issues like that so I
I would certainly suggest that there is
some process by which people can obtain
you know expungement of their records my
suggestion is it might be less
burdensome on the state
um if that was um but but like you said
there's some things we can do today with
this bill and some things we might have
okay I was just making that suggestion
yeah yeah okay if you if you do we are
aware of the problem but that that
probably needs to come after we've done
something first okay well again I'm just
concerned that uh that it you know could
derail things because people could be
you know
you know feel that that contradiction
was uh you know unjust so anyway that's
uh great all I had to add all right
thank you very much
thank you uh
chair we'll call on Sue homo
thank you very much for the opportunity
to testify today uh the purpose of this
testimony is not to re uh reiterate the
numerous ways in which recreational
marijuana negatively impacts the states
in which it is legalized that
information has been presented to the
committee it's presented to the house
it's presented to the Senate and yet and
yet here we are keep we keep trying even
though
um
even though they're we don't want to
accept the data in science that's out
there on that the focus of this
testimony is actually to discuss the
amendment uh for this amendment and to
discuss the two key additions that I saw
in the bill they've already been uh
brought up and I'll just quickly go over
page five line 19. it adds to the
definition of a cannabis store is
operated by the state of New Hampshire
the other addition to this this is that
was not included in the original HP 39
language the second thing that I saw was
page seven lines 23 through 35. there's
three new sections sections one two and
three what these additions do is they
identify that all Cannabis stores will
be operated by the state it carves out
an operating system where decision
making of this program goes directly
through the Liquor Commission and
bypasses administrative rulemaking with
administer with legislative oversight
and it gives the commission authority to
contract almost all aspects of this new
business with private contractors
what this is doing is this is actually
giving the impromater of having a
state-run recreational marijuana program
while quietly allowing private marijuana
businesses to be the ones to nearly
sustain the whole operation
uh this is seems to me it's a bit of a
quasi version of Last sessions 1598
without uh without the state banking
system and also without the liability
protections for uh marijuana retail
employees
these additions to the language are
significant and they rate being
discussed in a more public fashion in a
more open fashion rather than having
them buried into the text of a
multi-page Amendment
these changes actually make the
amendment look like it was a rushed
attempt to respond to Governor snooda's
request for recreational marijuana bill
that he very mistakenly feels will
legalize this drug in a way that can be
controlled and doesn't harm Granite
Staters
through the governor's flip-flop on
recreational marijuana in the ninth hour
of the lettuce legislative session to
this committee's willingness to jam in
this bill that's already been shot down
in the Senate
into the amendment language actually
that quietly changes some very
fundamental parts of this of the intent
of this language it's clear that this
isn't any way to legislate
the whole scenario tells me that this
committee is no longer doing the will of
the people it's trying to do an end
round around the Senate and instead of
spending the last week's uh finalizing
some of the bills it's looking to play
politics with legislation I apologize if
that offends anybody but it just seems
like it
this is wrong it shouldn't be happening
this amendment should be a standalone
bill that it's introduced next year so
they can be just discussed properly and
out in the open
and I would I know that some of the
discussion today was on labeling and on
dosing and I just wanted to add to that
that the late I'm glad that Mr Holt
discussed labeling and dosing and that
was a comment that you all had
labeling and dosing for the medical
marijuana program is currently not as
adequate as it should be and there needs
to be more patient education that was
identified in Senate bill 180. it was
successfully passed in the Senate and
then this bill took that public the
consumer protection Bill and retained it
it was a good bill and it actually
deserves your your second look it
actually deserves to be moved forward if
Public Public Health oversight is your
main goal
uh I would like to say in closing I just
have one request and I and this is I've
not heard this today but in all of the
discussion about recreational marijuana
the one thing that people keep saying is
that is that they're doing it for the
will of the people because there's
overwhelming public demand well there's
not and we know that the UNH poll that
always gets cited is flawed and the
better poll to be looking at would be
Emerson College which shows the majority
majority of New Hampshire residents
actually are not clamoring for
legalization and it's time for
legislators so stop using people as
human Shields so you can justify
marijuana for State profit
if public demand was the utmost
importance of everything you do the nine
people in this room would not would have
voted for parental rights because 80
percent of families and parents want
that nearly 80. well thank you
all I'm saying is all I'm saying is
all I'm saying is that don't use
pump the will of the people as an excuse
I respectfully request that you do not
Advance this amendment
ushering legislation this way is wrong
in the behavior only communicates to the
public view that this is a legislative
game and not a serious effort to have a
discussion on a solemn topic
thank you
chair will call on Matt Simon from
primeatc
excuse me Mr chairman is it not
customary to ask after someone testifies
if there are any questions
did you have a question I'm sorry I
looked around I didn't see anybody's
hand up I didn't well uh do we have to
signify by raising hands before you ask
the question I will make sure that I ask
just asking procedurally if we're not
going to have questions no I I I thought
it was just an oversight okay thank you
had an oversight
good morning Matt good morning Mr
chairman
for the record Matt Simon I represent
Prime ATC you all know me by now been
here several times this year
I felt a little bit like Charles Dickens
trying to decide how to testify on this
bill
is the worst best of amendments it was
the worst of amendments not entirely
sure what we're talking about here so
I'll comment on
two ways that this could be interpreted
I'm guilty of having read page four
lines 31 30 and 31 where it says a dual
use certificate means license allowing
an alternative treatment center to
co-locate with and operate a retail
cannabis store
and I
certainly thank you
as I said page four lines 30 31 say dual
use certificates mean license allowing
alternative treatment center
to operate to co-locate with and operate
a retail cannabis store so we were
taking that at its word and believing
that this was an attempt to actually
create a workable compromise between the
state control model and a model that
included Private Sales
so if that is what we're talking about I
think we're talking about a potentially
workable compromise if we're talking
about as a system that is only state-run
stores I think we're talking about an
unworkable boondoggle that we would have
no choice but to absolutely oppose for
the reasons we opposed House Bill 1598
last year
so I want to back up a little bit having
made that comment I want to say I
appreciate the comments that have come
from the corner office focusing on harm
reduction and the the primary goal of
cannabis regulation should be to reduce
harms that has been my message for the
last 15 years there are harms associated
with prohibition that can only be
resolved and addressed via responsible
regulation
so evaluating this amendment on that
basis would the amendment actually
reduce harms well we'll reduce some
harms any legalization bill would reduce
some harms because adults would no
longer be fined or arrested for cannabis
possession that's why there's so much
impetus to get this done thousands of
granite Staters are driving across the
border coming back with cannabis they're
being fined and arrested it's unjust it
should end tomorrow
there are a whole other set of harms
that are prohibition related harms these
are harms that you can only end if you
create a functional regulatory system
and create a market that actually works
would this bill create a functional
regulated market for cannabis in my
opinion it would not if it if it is
amended to clearly allow sales by atcs
and agency stores then probably yes if
it's limited to state-run stores the
most likely result is that it will be as
I said an unworkable boondoggle so what
I've given you is written testimony is
an op-ed published by my former
colleague Karen O'Keefe with the
marijuana policy project it ran in the
Concord Monitor today I hope every
member of the general court will take
time to read this op-ed because Karen is
an attorney who has been dealing with
the intersection of federal and state
cannabis policies for about 20 years
she is seen every state that has thought
about going down this road to state-run
stores
try it on sounds like a good idea and
then you get a few steps down the road
and they all back out they all stop
because it is a direct conflict with
federal law it's very different for a
state to pass a law that merely licenses
private entities to risk Federal arrest
and prosecution because make no that
mistake that is what we're doing
uh to be engaging in this business is to
commit federal crimes so these can
either be done
there is Federal Protection in the form
of a budget amendment but we are dealing
with a situation where cannabis is still
illegal under federal law
and we have a federal policy that
tolerates State cannabis sales as long
as they're regulated
but no state has taken the step of
actually running its own stores and I
simply don't believe they will I think
the most likely
outcome is they won't do it and there
won't be any stores
so
we have expressed repeatedly a
willingness to compromise on this we
just we demonstrated during the process
for 639 we're perfectly willing to
accept the Liquor Commission as a
regulatory agency they have zero
experience with cannabis as far as I
know they've never touched a cannabis
plant
but we're willing to trust that they can
deal with the Steep learning curve that
will exist and do this if the law is
written correctly as we thought 639 was
we're willing to accept even that
state-run stores can be part of a
successful Statewide policy but what we
cannot accept is that excluding atcs
from retail sales is in any way
consistent with the principles of harm
reduction
therapeutic cannabis program is a harm
reduction program our mission is harm
reduction we dispense cannabis we've
been doing it for six and a half years
the three atcs between them have about
20 years experience dispensing cannabis
in compliance with strict regulations
the last few years we've had oversight
from 11 medical professionals on the
therapeutic medical cannabis medical
oversight board
we've been under a microscope since day
one the opponents who fought against
therapeutic cannabis have been waiting
for the single slightest screw-up so
they can come in here and try to take
our program away try to clamp down on it
there have been no reports of problems
associated with the atcs and their
dispensing of cannabis we've been a
model of successful very limited model
but a model of successful regulation and
as Mr Holt said if this bill Amendment
were to pass as is it the most likely
result well there are two sets of likely
result one is that it won't be
implemented in which case you've got a
boondoggle the other is that it is
actually implemented successfully and
maybe interstate commerce happens and
you can import cannabis from somewhere
else well we don't need the atcs anymore
we don't need the therapeutic cannabis
program anymore we're just going to have
state-run stores and that's going to be
the way so we can't sit idly by and
pretend that that's okay
wiping away everything that we've worked
for to build a successful therapeutic
cannabis program over the last seven
years everything that Prime ATC staff
has worked hard for uh would be placed
in serious risk
so
I
since this committee did not consider HB
1598 that was in the criminal justice
committee last year I'd like to hit a
few of the talking points that I hit a
lot last year when we were dealing with
1598. there's a lot of people who love
the state liquor stores and it's easy to
understand why if you like alcohol you
walk into a state liquor store you see
rum from Jamaica you see the best
bourbon from Kentucky you see sake from
Japan
representative almie's favorite wine is
always there unless they have a bad year
and then it's not there but the product
selection is amazing the prices are
lower than neighboring states it's very
consumer friendly so people might assume
that state-run cannabis store will be
similar
the only way it can be similar is if
interstate commerce happens and you're
able to import California and Oregon and
all these other states products we can't
assume that will happen next year we
have no idea when that might happen
until it happens cannabis markets have
to be entirely intrastate which means no
product will be on the Shelf of the
state-run cannabis store unless a New
Hampshire business produced that product
now what kind of business is going to
invest money
in a program where the most likely
result is it's not even going to be
implemented and we're going to spend a
bunch of money and not be able to bring
our products to Market
that sounds like a recipe for absolute
disaster Financial ruin for businesses
policy embarrassment for the state it is
not appealing to us in any way
um
as has been said if Growers and
processors don't like the prices offered
by the state it's a crime to sell to
literally anybody else
if you're a distiller in New Hampshire
you can sell your New Hampshire made rum
to anybody in the world that wants to
buy it but if you're a cannabis grower
in New Hampshire and you know like the
deal you're getting from the Liquor
Commission you're suddenly going to feel
like a farmer in the former Soviet Union
because you have no recourse
and if you do sell it outside the system
that would be a felony and you might
wind up in the New Hampshire equivalent
of a gulag
let's not go down this road please Mr
chairman
so with regard to the therapeutic canvas
program we've already reached a point of
basically stagnant growth it's because
cannabis is available across the border
in every direction in cheap stores the
prices have plummeted because there are
hundreds of producers
Maine is essentially the wild Northeast
of cannabis there are hundreds and
hundreds of very lightly regulated
medical cannabis producers
a little known fact they don't even
require independent lab testing in the
therapeutic cannabis Market in Maine so
that's a cost that's imposed on New
Hampshire atcs that is not imposed on
Main operators we Face a number of major
operating disadvantages relative to less
heavily regulated businesses in
neighboring states
we want effective regulation
we want it for adult use just as we want
it for therapeutic cannabis
this amendment doesn't do it unless we
are talking about a version that allows
atcs to sell cannabis so if we are happy
to discuss
compromise and if not it's really nice
outside let's enjoy the beautiful
weather and see what happens in a study
commission thank you Mr chair okay thank
you very much representative Philo
thank you for your testimony you
mentioned that two possible options
outcomes of this bill would be either
that we pass it and decide to not go
through with it or that the therapeutic
cannabis have uh program were to fall
apart as a result of this bill being
passed would a third possible outcome be
that we actually pass the Bill
implements it in that that somebody
withstanding were to sue in the federal
courts the entire program becomes
enjoined and the state has
tar on its face as a result of having a
program that it passed being joined by
the federal government
thank you for the question
representative I did not mean to suggest
that there are only two possible
outcomes I think the outcome you
describe is contained within the first
outcome of it won't be implemented and
will be at boondoggle thank you
okay we do have more questions
representative Burroughs
thank you thanks for taking my question
I just want to understand
um your position I I know where you're
at with the atcs and and the retail
outlet are you also envisioning other
types of of retail uh stores being run
by entrepreneurs
thank you for the question uh as you
know we advocated for HB 639 which would
have created a robust free market
approach to cannabis we have never asked
for a special treatment at all we want
to create a fair market that bill would
have allowed adult use businesses to to
serve the therapeutic cannabis program
if they got a therapeutic cannabis
endorsement we put a lot of thought how
to make this not special treatment for
the atcs but we're that being said not
going to stand idly by while something
passes that would wipe out our program
and take away our reason to exist and we
think it would do that if it restricts
or if it doesn't allow ET sale ATC sales
another question yeah and just to
clarify again you're saying no to State
one Cannabis stores
no I I didn't say that I thought we were
here to talk about a potential
compromise the amendment as I read it
would have been an improvement over HB
1598 it would have allowed both
privately owned agency stores which I
knew nothing about until I started
reading about them but they would be
somewhat they would be privately owned
and operated but very much tied into the
to the state system and that would be
one option and allowing atcs to engage
in Private Sales would be another option
I thought we were talking about a hybrid
approach that would allow some ATC
stores some agency stores some state-run
stores if in fact they are viable and
that we would be talking about a viable
compromise thanks
okay representative McAleer uh thank you
Mr chairman
um last night we uh as Representatives
got also got a letter from Karen O'Keefe
and I thought you were sort of going
there because she talked about a a
safety valve to get out if you read this
particular letter and but you just you
sort of didn't go there could you
explain how that would work
well it's it's not my position to
advocate for a safety valve I worked for
that Organization for 10 years and
Karen's good friend of mine and former
colleague but uh
her her ask was twofold either have a
safety valve or allow Private Sales by
atcs uh from our perspective if it's
just a safety valve it's it's not
sufficient to save the therapeutic
canvas program if the state stores were
to become operational if interstate
commerce were to to take to become
viable we would be wiped out
represent Gibbs thank you uh doesn't
this Amendment provide for dual use
licenses so that atcs could
um uh also do recreational Cannabis
business
thank you for the question
representative that is exactly what it
says on page four line 30 and 31 and
there are references throughout the bill
to dual use certificates and and and
dispensing and things like that but
there are also two places in the bill
where it says all retail stores shall be
run by the state I initially thought the
intent was the workable compromise and
there have been amendments suggested to
clean up that language and make it clear
that the compromise version is what was
actually intended but what I've been
hearing this morning is not that so
again it is the best of amendments and
it is the worst of amendments
so the question there is
um if there was a compromise then we
would have to create a tax for you
I didn't say that we needed to create a
tax I said that we need to have a system
there needs to be some imagination
because the state's planning to extract
revenue from Cannabis sales without
having attacks so
there is probably a way to do that
within the code the only other way we've
done it through liquor is we have agency
stores but those agency stores are
getting the product wholesale through
the commission so they're paying a
markup
if in other words if you that that puts
this way you couldn't be a cultivator
and a retailer because the cultivator
provides the product to the commission
then the commission would provide the
product back to the ATC so that would be
the problem you'll have to figure out in
the next week
well I don't know that I'm the one that
needs to figure it out Mr chairman but I
it seems to me that we would be selling
products other than the ones that we
produce and the products we produce
would be coming from The Liquor
Commission system and therefore it would
already be ex the the profit or tax or
whatever the revenue would already be
extracted before we get it I don't know
how it would handle the products we
produce whether we would have to sell
them to the Liquor Commission and buy
them back to sell to adults I don't know
that's at least viable in concept
cutting us out of sales is not viable
fair enough okay
you know anybody else any more questions
great thank you very much uh we're we're
behind on time so I asked people who
when they come up could you please uh be
a model of brevity
uh next up is uh Jim Riddle
uh who supports the bill
you the hemp farmer
I am okay
I tried not to look like a farmer today
right yeah my name is Jim Riddle Mr
chair members of the committee uh thank
you for holding this hearing
um I also uh I lived at Hillsboro New
Hampshire and I serve as a policy
advisor for NH can the New Hampshire
cannabis Association but the comments I
offered today are on my own behalf fair
enough I do hold a USDA uh hemp grower
license I'm holding it right now
to produce seeds
but under my license requirements a USDA
rules
I have to destroy any plant materials
that exceed 0.3 percent THC
and I can do that by burying them
burning them composting them and I love
making compost so that's not a problem
seeds are what I'm interested in and the
DEA it was mentioned previously has
officially determined that any cannabis
seeds regardless of their genetic
potential are hemp
they don't contain THC
um and that is one part of your bill in
the definition of cannabis that should
be amended by removing seeds seeds
belong in the definition and description
of hemp that's in that definition of
cannabis and seed growers should not be
regulated under any uh cannabis we're
already regulated under the USDA hemp
program
but I'm ready to invest in craft
cannabis
and turn those byproducts at compost
into valuable product
but only in a open competitive market
um
it's on May 6th and 7th my wife and I to
celebrate our 38th wedding anniversary
attended to Vermont cannabis and hemp
Expo near Burlington
I I was really impressed by the turnout
there were well over 2 000 people in
attendance but what really impressed me
was the exhibitors there were over 120
exhibits and the number and variety of
businesses that are supporting uh uh
cannabis is what I really was I expected
to see cultivators and dispensaries but
there were Bankers with booths insurance
companies greenhouse builders Farm
suppliers labeling packaging companies
Security Services web designers seed
companies Cosmetics
accounting engineering state agencies
universities and much more and the the
whole Expo was just a buzz and I
don't mean that as people being buzzed
it was a buzz of economic activity
people were making deals I mean all over
the place and it was really encouraging
to see you and I even met people from
New Hampshire that were there investing
in the Vermont market now that's money
that's just going out of state just like
all the consumers that are driving
across the borders and then driving back
um
but I've been uh you know listening to
the uh debate uh here in the legislature
and one of the most promising things
I've learned is research showing that
cannabis legalization has been shown
repeatedly now to decrease dependency on
opioids
and one of the studies the title is
cannabis significant significantly
reduces the use of prescription opioids
and improves the quality of life and
authorities and authorized patients
results of a large perspective study and
that study concluded the high rate of
Cannabis used for chronic pain and the
subsequent reductions in opioid use
suggest that cannabis may play a harm
reduction role in the opioid overdose
crisis potentially improving the quality
of life of patients and overall Public
Health
with your leadership we have a chance to
help stop
at least put a good dent in New
Hampshire's opioid epidemic
we can keep the Cannabis dollars in our
state while capturing revenue for drug
abuse prevention and treatment
we have a chance to stop unnecessary
arrests and incarceration
and redirect police resources to focus
on real crimes
we can provide income for farmers and
businesses and stimulate economic
activity if done right
now finally I urge you to amend the bill
that you're considering to allow home
cultivation I know this is Steve Hill
but especially for medical cannabis
patients
and HB 611 already passed the house it's
been tabled by the Senate
um
I think it's really important that
especially medical patients have the
ability to choose what varieties what
strains what balance is best for them
and I think the atcs do a great job but
they
aren't everywhere it's a it's a big uh
Hassle and cost and and also uh just not
available for people
um to always drive to them or to find
what they're looking for and
just
there's been comment that you can't grow
good cannabis outdoors in New Hampshire
and that's just simply not true in fact
more and more research in the Cannabis
trade is showing that outdoor Sun grown
that gets exercised from the wind that
gets attacked by pests
actually produces much more uh balanced
terpenes those are like the flavor
profile of cannabis that's what has
different effects out whereas indoor
grown is like comparing a tomato from a
greenhouse to one that was grown
outdoors in your Healthy soil in your
garden it's just has much more
complexity uh so and you certainly there
are varieties that will finish in a 120
day if you can grow peaches you can grow
pot
okay thank you
we learned something new every day great
thank you very much do we have any
questions representative McAleer uh
thank you Mr chairman
um just a quick clarification when you
say that a homegrown pot are you talking
about only people that have a medical
card or anybody well there's a bill uh
thank you for your question there's a
bill that's tabled by the Senate that
would only allow medical card holders
that would be a good place to start
because that bill already exists it's
been heard and the Senate didn't kill it
they tabled it so that's a good starting
point but to me if there's going to be a
monopoly run by the state and the atcs
that's not many
much variety I think the compromise the
balance is okay seeds are already in
interstate commerce I can order any seed
I want the post office will deliver it
because the DEA has said seeds are hemp
and so people can get seeds it's not a
problem to get seeds of any kind of
strain you want that interstate commerce
is already happening there so why not
balance the state control State making
money atcs making the money with people
making having Freedom Liberty to make
their own choices so that's but start
with the medical because the bill
already exists
thank you
yeah representative
my only question is
you support the bill
I like the previous speaker I have mixed
feelings I support legalization I do not
support a soviet-style state-run
monopoly
now if the atcs can stay in it and
especially if you can allow medical
homegrown I think you got a good bill
okay any other questions from the
committee none thank you very much thank
you
uh Heather Brown you didn't put any time
so but can you promise me you'll be
quick and not say anything new or
different or say only things new nothing
I tend not to put a time because you
know sometimes you give me more than 30
seconds and I appreciate it
I've never been known to cut anybody off
but don't be the first
proceed
I would like to say that I appreciate
the efforts that individuals have made
at tackling the issue regarding
legalization
unfortunately
literally I believe lines
sorry don't worry about the lines just
give us the point I just want to tell
you sir thank you for my opportunity
literally lines 1 through 28
are excellent in this bill the rest of
the bill should be tossed this is an
awful Amendment this is horrible
line 29 on the first page actually
states that no one other than the state
would be able to be involved in the
retail sales of cannabis
has a member of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board I believe that
this bill this amendment jeopardizes the
future of the therapeutic cannabis
program it puts all of our patients at
risk it puts our atcs at risk it puts it
opens it opens up a door for patients to
have to resort to the black market or to
traveling over state lines more so than
what they are already doing
I do not think New Hampshire should be
going backwards in regards to cannabis I
think we should be moving forward I do
not believe this bill moves forward for
everyone that would potentially utilize
cannabis whether they are patient or not
I think that
it is appreciated by all of us and there
is nobody in this room that wants
legalization more than what I do but
this is not the way to do it
jeopardizing one group of people for the
sake of the state being able to make a
little extra money is inappropriate I as
a patient if I lose the therapeutic
cannabis program then I myself would be
forced either to revert back to crossing
state lines or into the black market
because even proposed the system
proposed in this bill would not be able
to allow me to treat my medical
conditions in the same way that I have
been treating them for the last several
years I should not be put into that
position neither should any other
patient within the state
I have to agree although I appreciated
his statements on allowing medical
homegrow I don't think that this bill
would allow that as an option or that
that's even a thought for it I believe
that really at this point I mean I I
know that the governor came around and
made the statements that he made and I
know that another individual said you
know
you shouldn't hide behind doing it for
the people well I am one of your people
and I do want legalization but I do not
want it in this fashion I believe that
the individuals that should be able to
participate in this market
are the citizens of New Hampshire if
you're worried about creating a
marijuana mile like we've seen in many
other states then please put licensing
caps in put caps in in regards to how
many particular businesses can be
allowed in a particular area do it that
way it is very possible make New
Hampshire unappealing to out-of-state
large cannabis corporations that would
come in here and decimate the market
just like they have done in Maine just
like they have done in Massachusetts and
just like they have done it out in
California in Colorado and many other
areas
you know if you want New Hampshire to be
different than the rest of the nation
that has legalized then let's put caps
let's put restrictions let's not allow
every individual to be able to have a
license to be able to open a business
put the restrictions in that way don't
make it so that the only people that are
allowed to participate
sufficiently and successfully within
cannabis in New Hampshire is the state
itself
that's doing an injustice to the people
that you are here to represent
okay
represent Herbert
my question is how many stores do we
have in this system
we have a hundred liquor stores 100
give or take
so we have a cap on how many stores can
have marijuana if this if this passes
this way we're not going to sell
marijuana in the liquor stores they
would be new Standalone stores
why aren't we okay that's a good I did
not know that I thought this the stores
were going to be no a portion of a state
liquor store no they're going to be
Standalone stores
that's that's
there is a cap in my mind and maybe
that's I'm incorrect but there's take
the hundred stores
now they're standalones I find out and
that is a cap and I understand that if a
city like Manchester says we don't want
them
they can't be in Manchester
uh and and so I'm I'm a little confused
as to
your your
um your point of view that
we have a cap uh a number but it's not
the right number for you
no my point was in reference to if you
allowed a system where private citizens
could participate in the Cannabis Market
where they could be the ones to sell it
retail produce cultivate and manufacture
this bill does not allow it if private
citizens were allowed to enter the
market that is where it would also be
necessary to take care of some of these
concerns and worries that individuals
have raised
by instilling caps
by creating a restriction on how many of
what business can be allowed in any
particular area one more question please
is any of the states that have
accepted uh made made marijuana legal
are any of those States uh have the
retail orientation we have here in New
Hampshire nobody's done it done its way
this way but no other state has caps
either
actually I mean they're saying all these
terrible things and I'm going well these
states don't have regulation actually to
to form a correction okay
um a lot of the other states do have
caps in regards but it's more on the
municipality level and you will find
that a lot of the communities that are
more free and open with cannabis will
allow more cannabis businesses so say
just as an example in Lebanon there are
licensing caps in Lebanon but with the
way that their Lebanon Maine with the
way that their rules and their laws are
written the only place that retail
businesses are allowed is on 202. so
that is why you have quote unquote a
marijuana mile on 202 it's because that
is the old Place Lebanon allows retail
business fair enough
okay thank you very much
okay I only have a couple more cards
left so again I urge everyone to be as
brief as possible uh Frank Knack from
the ACLU
h
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Frank Knack I'm
the policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire you might want to take your
mask off thank you
um I'm the policy director with the Ace
of New Hampshire uh for chairman hunt
thank you so much for bringing this
amendment if you think this is an issue
that is important and cannot be kicked
down the road
um we also you know appreciate the
leadership of both parties in the house
for their efforts to push us through
this session
um we agree so I think you all received
amendments from Paul Toomey I think two
of the four were included in this and we
we suggest that you incorporate the
other two I think those would address
the issues that you've heard concerns
around
um thus far but I want to back this up a
lot of the conversation we've heard
today has been around money and revenue
and who's going to make what and where
that money is going to go and I think we
really want to back it up to the fact
that we really agree with what the
governor said uh two Fridays ago when he
talked about this is not about money
this is about harm reduction in
additional harm reduction from our
perspective this is about racial Justice
and so I just want to give you all some
data points marijuana is that perfect
issue where we can compare apples to
apples in the criminal legal system
because we know as a baseline that black
people and white people use marijuana at
roughly the same rate yet nationally
people black people are 3.5 times more
likely to be arrested for marijuana
possession so Stark racial disparity
nationally in New Hampshire it's even
worse in New Hampshire according to the
most recent data I think from 2021 and
so this is UCR data that agencies give
to the to FBI black people are 4.6 times
more likely to be arrested than white
people and this is again the state's own
data so this is fundamentally about
racial Justice and right and wrong and
if we're talking about you know well
this is we we don't have perfect right
now and we're just going to kick this
can down the road what we're doing is
kicking can down the road of this racial
Injustice that's happening every day in
New Hampshire in addition we're still
arresting again according to the most
recent data over 1100 people every
single year in our state for simple
possession of marijuana and so while
we've heard often times in testimony
that many of these people are no longer
going to jail all those people are being
unnecessarily brought into our criminal
legal system and having the possibility
of jail time but also the fines and fees
that are associated with an arrest that
can have devastating collateral
consequences they also leave you with a
criminal record so when you're trying to
get a job when you're trying to get
housing even child custody issues
marijuana possession
can be problematic and before this um so
because there's no like easy way to find
all the various collateral consequences
there's some great clearinghouses so I
looked at the national inventory of
collateral consequences of conviction
which is a great National Clearinghouse
that tracks all state-level collateral
consequences and I went to New Hampshire
and looked at just misdemeanor mandatory
collateral consequences so there could
be additional because it's a drug but
just looking at mandatory collateral
consequences that attach if you have a
misdemeanor conviction we have 99
separate collateral consequences which
is absolutely ridiculous and so every
time we talk about postponing and not
dealing with this now for these 1100
plus people who were still arresting
every single year the collateral
consequences the fines the fees the
harms the racial Injustice because of
our disparities track with that and so
from our perspective we can no longer
kick this can down the road we
appreciate the leadership's effort to
get this done we think this is a good
Amendment there's some few small tweaks
that we hope that you all incorporate
that I know Paul to me his email to the
members we hope that you'll do that and
happy to answer any questions
representative Gibbs
thank you
um just for clarity uh you mentioned
that 1100 people every year uh
approximately 1100 are arrested for
marijuana possession and that is after
decriminalization am I correct yes so
that is 2021 data FBI UCR data and that
was after decriminalization yes that was
I think back in 2018 yep thank you thank
you
okay thank you very much thank you so
much all right got three cards left uh
Kevin Pratt
who's in pose to the bill
and I'll hold you to the two minutes
please
I'm all set a lot of my questions are
already answered I didn't realize it was
representative Pratt I apologize sooner
that's all right uh will this bill be
coming back to criminal justice and
Public Safety no no okay because Sandy
is no uh
local control where the bill looks does
local control lose the ability for
licensing of these facilities no they
would be able to say to the commission
we don't want any store in our town okay
good
uh and about growing facilities also the
same way for growing facilities
cultivators yes the cultivators too okay
and well we just wanted to make a
statement that Raymond has a liquor
store so it sounds like now it doesn't
have to be in the liquor store it's not
intended to be in liquor stores it's
tend to be a standalone store Raymond
doesn't want any head shops thank you
I'm all day perfect thank you
okay uh Paul I had a question oh we do
have a question I'm sorry
representative Waltz has a question by
the way I believe uh that this is an opt
in issue correct so I just want to make
it as opposed to opt out and it would be
better for towns to be able to
opt-in is better yeah opt-in is better
but isn't this opt out this is opt-in oh
it is in opt-in okay thank you
good thank you okay
uh Paul massetti
foreign
reps representative Representatives my
name is Paul Morrissette and I'm a
partner in East Coast cannabis uh in War
of Maine uh we're we have uh uh several
stores and uh we were vertically
integrated so we do cultivation and
Manufacturing
um the partners in this business around
New Hampshire boys the CEOs here Dana
breeley and he's went to Concord High
School so we're not Maine people we'd
love to do business in the state of New
Hampshire
um
unfortunately we're cultivators and
we're manufacturers and I wanted to go
quickly quickly through the three
kinds of things that happen during call
during cannabis business and their
cultivation and Manufacturing and Retail
so under under cultivation I think the
problem with the state isn't the stores
the stores are fine anybody can operate
a store the problem is you're the sole
buyer and um it's impossible to estimate
the crops size so if we're let's take
cultivation for example right let's say
you guys issue 20 license I think I've
seen that somewhere there right we're
either gonna undergrow or overgrow and
we can't tell when we're putting a crop
in exactly what it's going to weigh so
basically whether you've got a state
buyer or you have us giving you us all
the information it's impossible to
estimate the size of the crops so uh
your supply will either be short or
Worse the supply will be in excess of
the market which will result in two
outcomes a oversupply which will crash
the price and will ensue I'm talking
cultivation or B at some point organic
crops will spoil and have to be
destroyed since there was only one
customer who doesn't need or want that
product bankruptcies of licensed
cultivators will insude costing Untold
Millions to private businesses who
trusted the state system that failed
lawsuits probably will be inevitable the
only way to avoid this scenario is for
the state to contractually agree to buy
everything a grower can produce which of
course will bankrupt The Liquor
Commission
next Manufacturing
most most manufacturers one of the
products they make is gummies and other
common products but the state will have
limited space for each products on their
stores in their stores and since there
won't be room for everyone's brand of
gummies much will be destroyed along
with other products bankrupting
manufacturers who trusted the state
system that failed there's no way to
control Supply there's no way to control
what you need to have like cultivation
the only way to avoid this scenario is
for the state to buy all products
manufacturers produce which of course
will bankrupt The Liquor Commission
you'll be taking the risk instead of us
um retail since the state sets the price
to pay for all products there is no
incentive to develop new or high quality
products your state stores will be
stocked with low and mid-grade at best
products cultivators and manufacturers
have no incentive to develop new or
better products since the state will set
the price and may not even want the
product in their stores so
my position is this can't fly because
it's not feasible for the supply chain
that they have set up it we set up grows
in Maine for millions and millions of
dollars okay and I'm going to trust the
state buyer to come in and give me a
fair price for my product and understand
these flower products they aren't all
the same Outdoors relatively cheap and
then there's different grades and types
and strains of indoors by the hundreds
and thousands depends on the quality
it's like buying wine so I have a hard
time figuring how a state person is
going to come in and negotiate after I
spent seven million dollars to put up a
grow how in the world I'm going to come
to a price with him with the Cannabis
the other problems is it's state to
state if he uses Massachusetts for
example Massachusetts recently crashed
over supplied Mains having some of the
same problem right where's the price is
going to come that he's going to pay me
based on a failed Market or based on a
New Hampshire Market which he doesn't
know what to pay for and why would he
pay me a lot he's going to push me down
you know and you're going to get to the
point where nobody's making money we've
talked to many Growers across many
states and you can ask Matt Simon I
think he told me he has too I haven't
found one person we'd love to be part of
this in our own state but we cannot
justify spending millions and millions
of dollars to put up a cannabis
cultivation and Manufacturing to supply
the state who's going to decide whether
they're going to buy it at all and if
they do what they're going to pay me for
my product can you think of any other
business where that happens it certainly
don't happen in the Liquor Commission
Smirnoff ain't telling you know we ain't
telling Smirnoff what to pay for the
Vodka so my problem with this is I just
I want to see legalization here on want
to participate in this just structurally
is not going to work and the state's
going to buy the liability when this all
fails and um that's basically it
questions
representative kibbs thank you
uh I have two questions uh the first one
is basically yes or no and I should
point out that um I grew up in an
agricultural family
isn't agriculture a risky type of
business oh absolutely we all know you
can go down and buy some tomatoes and
plant them on the side of your deck but
if I asked you how many pounds you're
going to get out of those Tomatoes when
you're done you can't tell me that we
have other problems like we get bugs and
the crops has to be destroyed or mold or
something like that or pathogens we're
we're in Maine we're tested at the
recreational level they mentioned before
there's no testing in Maine that's
Medical but we're tested for everything
okay second question uh
thank you uh uh how would you propose to
correct the problem that you described
I throw this bill in the trash and start
over with a good bill that has an open
Natural Market for the Live Free or Die
State and you know allows allow stores
and the atcs and anybody else that wants
to get in business we'd suggest small
smaller tiering of licenses okay to not
bring the big corporate guys that you're
talking in here you know so so
cultivation you know is smaller you know
and to have a free and open market just
like we do with everything else in the
state and you know that's it are you
suggesting that we put limits on how
much they cultivate
I'm not suggesting what you just said
what did you just say for a limitation
no I didn't I didn't well that's what
it's selling so what was your what was
your saying that small
we'd like to have a lot of small a
smaller businesses participate in this
so how do we make a business how do we
ensure that how do we insure that yeah
we have a we have a free and open market
and we allow Heather for free open
market means they could be as big as
they want how do we keep them you're
saying small I understand how does the
state legislate that they be small and I
didn't dictate that they'd be small I
think you allow anybody you could how do
you dictate that they're small you set
the tiers and the sizes for the grows or
the manufacturing you limit the square
footage
set the tears for the growing in other
words we're going to tell them how much
they can grow we're going to tell them
okay in Maine for for cultivation right
there's four tiers of cultivation you've
got tier one that's up to 500 square
feet you've got tier two that's up to
two thousand square feet of budding
space you've got tier three which is
seven thousand and you got tier four
which is twenty thousand okay so the
largest license in Maine is twenty
thousand now if you go to Massachusetts
okay who has a much bigger problem their
their license is a hundred thousand okay
and a big company called true Leaf came
in there and they built the giant grow
200 people worked there over a hundred
thousand square feet okay recently in
the last five or six months the markets
crash because there's too much in the
market they had twenty thousand pounds
of an organic sitting on a shelf you
know waiting to be thrown away or just
destroyed you know we have to have good
policy I would limit uh like I think
somebody else brought up I'd say three
three stores from the same
but you know you can only have ownership
in three stores and uh that'll limit a
lot of the big guys from coming in
because they don't want to do that you
know they want they want a big okay
Representative Vincent has a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks a lot for
taking my question
um so most likely this bill is going to
have a bunch of amendments tacked onto
it say the bill has a bunch of
amendments but it keeps the growth but
but the state keeps the control
wouldn't it be would you before getting
this bill at least getting your foot in
the door and when the state realizes
that they're not going to make it or
they're going to fail we'd have changes
to it so put through a bill that we
physically don't think will work in the
long run and because it's something I I
don't want to do well listen it's not
the first time that the state's done
this however however remember are you
asking another question yes thank you
very much Mr chairman if I may you may
ask one more it was kind of like kind of
the same question but thank you very
much I appreciate that
uh remember where this is coming from
with no disrespect from the corner
office so we're trying to I mean that's
the way it's going to pass yeah and okay
and I'm not in disagreement with you
come on
thank you Mr chairman I'm done thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
all right I got one card left uh he's
from Maine uh Dana barely and I'm sure
you don't have oh that's right you do
have a store right
oh you had a question
would you believe it it was a would you
believe I guess but it
hearing that it's would you believe that
hearing the discussion on the one hand
of a Live Free or Die model but on the
other hand discussion of tears and
regulations in no more than three stores
would you believe that I'm having a
difficulty reconciling the two of those
could you describe how you reconcile on
the one hand to live for your do you uh
Live Free or Die model of sales and on
the other hand
what I just heard is a discussion of a
very complex licensing system that seems
no different than they have a very just
getting a Liquor Commission involved
you're right so that is a that is a
great would you believe that it is hard
to to fix that dichotomy okay so so
that's Dana is a partner he could
probably help answer that question I
could build some of these for sure thank
you Mr chair thank you all for hearing
me
um to avoid some redundancy I won't
speak on any of the topics that Paul
mentioned but I am a conquer High
graduate I grew up here in New Hampshire
and only ended up in Maine simply
because they had a program that would
allow me to flourish uh similar to what
Matt said here we're not asking for
anything of preference at the end of the
day we just want uh even playing field
which this bill doesn't allow for in its
current state
there's been a couple people that have
touched on federal illegality so I don't
think I need to speak much more to that
obviously there's a huge conflict of
interest here between what the feds want
and having state employees buy and sell
a federally illegal substance
two
markets don't work with one buyer period
in any industry there's a reason Most
states set up barriers to inhibit
monopolies unlike this proposal which
requires it what happens when the market
compresses and prices plummet as it does
in all states representative hunt you
mentioned negotiating wholesale
contracts before building our grows and
that would be contingent on Bank
financing so I'd like to dive into that
a little bit there is no institutional
funding in cannabis to start
any Bank under the FDIC cannot touch us
because the FDIC is federal majority of
capital raises are done with private
Equity who won't negotiate a weak
contract so let's look at the timeline
and costs associated
takes about a year to get a grow built
another 10 months until you have a crop
ready because it's Agriculture and that
takes time
and it's about call it seven to ten
million dollars in capex to get this
stood up then you so on those numbers
you've got about four years for the
operator to recoup their cap expenditure
that's five years since the Inception of
the contract that you suggested that our
businesses will potentially live or die
by so any somewhat Savvy operator will
negotiate multi-year contracts to
guarantee their Roi retail in Most
states however experienced significant
compression within the first three years
the problem here this estate will either
sustain massive losses if you negotiate
long-term contracts with Growers for
high wholesale prices so they can recoup
meanwhile retail is plummeting and
therefore no margins for the state-run
stores
we're not on an island here you're not
just competing with New Hampshire but
Mass Vermont and Maine where that price
compression is already occurring so you
either sell in line with their pricing
and lose a ton of State money to the
cultivation contracts or experience
significant dilution to neighboring
states it's a lose-lose
curiosity
with a show of hands how many people
here
use or have shopped at a cannabis store
you really don't think we're going to
admit to that do you if you travel on
vacation to Maine you buy in Maine you
use in Maine and you leave Maine you
realize that's leaving correct I have
driven by the main stores multiple times
but no I have not stepped put in one of
them yet all right
so representative Burroughs you brought
up dosing concerns that is a great point
in such a complex issue with Edibles
alone One Singular Lane of cannabis
products how five milligram affects me
versus one of you has a plethora of
variables What's Your Metabolism like
when was your last meal are you hydrated
what kind of concentrate was used Nano
emulsified concentrates are readily
available and provide effects within a
matter of minutes others take up to
hours therefore selling cannabis is more
in line with being a sommelier than
simply operating a point of sale in a
liquor store
or one of the new stores we're proposing
to build
our staff get trained for months
generally after coming from years of
experience either as a tender or a user
cannabis is highly complex which is why
the private sector should be able to
operate we know this inside and out
which is why our stores flourish I'm
curious to see how the state is going to
train hundreds of employees to safely
and knowledgeably help sell to cannabis
consumers of all ages sizes intolerance
at the high level necessary for the
safety of our customers which has been
mentioned a few times is the priority of
getting this bill across the gate
representative hunt you also mentioned
outdoor cultivation doesn't work in New
Hampshire
that it I'm wrong okay okay I was
curious yeah because all the neighboring
states it does very well and I just
checked in the bill and it looks better
it's better to get more tanning that
part I do agree with I disagree with but
at the end of the day what makes you
answer unique where it couldn't and I
think that bill will actually suggest
that outdoor cultivation gets three
times the square footage of indoor
operators
this is a weak Bill New Hampshire isn't
Texas it's geographically small and
surrounded by legal states with robust
successful programs there are a plethora
of successful programs Nationwide why
are we trying to reinvent the wheel
States like Oregon have tried that and
are now the pro proud owners of the
worst programs Nationwide
what I propose a similar in line with
what Paul just said cap it at three
stairs and cap it at 10 000 square feet
of cultivation
this will deter massive State out of
state players which ruin most markets it
will Empower municipalities to opt in or
opt out that is how you control your
quote-unquote green Miles and you allow
them to set up aggressive zoning
infrastructure like they have done in
multiple states that works extremely
well you're very concerned about green
Miles you know how you inhibit them you
limit them to a certain area if there's
100 liquor stores that's way more
exposure than a mile that's got four or
five and you're gonna have a lot more
Youth and whatever we're trying to deter
seeing them
is there any questions
Gibbs thank you
under this proposal while the business
goes through its Growing Pains does the
state stop arresting people for
marijuana and does the state stop wasted
law enforcement resources on marijuana
100 percent
okay 100 yeah I didn't hear your answer
oh I said 100 yes stop arresting people
for cannabis offenses yeah thank you
representative Philo
thank you for your testimony I'm
actually interested in the dosing and
the minimum dosing that should be
allowed uh particularly in Edibles and
other products the bill recommends five
do you actually recommend going to a
micro dosing do you think five is
appropriate uh where would you think we
should fall as a state there's a lot of
successful programs in the 10 milligram
range I think that's a good starting
number you know and as consumers get
educated when they're in these retail
stores you know like was mentioned
before start with five you know like
like a lot of substances it's tough to
undo start small and then grow within
your tolerance don't take out a huge
bite
yeah my understanding in Massachusetts
and they do have stores nearby me is I
have two in Winchendon
um that the a it's five milligrams but
then they limit to how much you can buy
on a per day basis so there is an
overall cap in terms of how much you can
buy
okay any other questions see none we
thank you very much thank you and with
that I will close the hearing on the uh
so um for the next bill committee
members uh we have seven cards they're
all two to three minutes
so if we get through we could do them
all the everybody's in support there's
no opposition to this bill are you guys
want to break for lunch or want to go
through this and get it done
Mr chairman can we take a one minute
break
one one minute oh I'm sorry yes yes we
can take it three minutes break three
minute break
no
hopefully they won't repeat themselves
foreign
okay
okay all right so we'll open up the um
public hearing on Senate Bill 85 and
hear from Ellen Plum uh MD
okay so we're going to hold you to your
three minutes
which I I pulled the mic yeah the red
butt light bun and then pull it close to
you make sure the red button and
you push the button just push the button
it'll yeah and really close you can see
how it's
is that good there you go okay good
morning chairman hunt and the members of
the House committee for Commerce and
consumer affairs my name is Ellen Plum
I'm a family physician with the New
Hampshire Academy of family physicians
and I'm a primary care provider
I come to you today not as an expert in
policy or in government spending but as
a clinician who is faced every day with
the realities of how mental illness and
behavioral emergencies are dealt with
within our communities I come today to
ask for your immediate support of Senate
Bill 85. our Primary Care on-call
coverage systems were created to help
patients who need basic medical guidance
they were not created to be psychiatric
crisis management and stabilization
strategies and yet suicidal patients
frequently call these Services first
knowing that they will reliably be
connected to a provider Health Care
settings across the state are
increasingly understaffed the workforce
needed to adequately triage clinical
requests results in delayed access to
point-of-care Services a concerning
reality when considering a potentially
life-threatening scenario like suicide I
work in a clinic with Behavioral Health
clinical teams that can support my work
and my patients but this is far from the
standard practice across the state where
patients have limited access to adequate
services to meet their needs psychiatric
complexity feels to be increasing in my
patient Community as our psychosocial
determinants of suicidality such as
chronic stress Financial insecurity and
housing instability this is a reality
that our Primary Care infrastructure and
Workforce was simply not designed to
sustain and yet we are asked to do so on
a daily basis
Primary Care Providers have neither the
time nor the training to safely and
competently stabilize a suicidal patient
over the phone we are unable to see them
on the demand and we certainly cannot
travel to meet them where they are at
yet we are routinely called upon to
intervene when a patient calls our
clinic in crisis we desperately need to
consider sustainable alternatives to
fund programs like the ones described in
SB 85 and to ensure that these services
are uniformly available to all patients
regardless of insurance status to that
end I strongly encourage you to vote in
support of SB 86 85 sorry thank you
great thank you very much for your
testimony do we have any questions
representative thank you
um do you know how many states are have
integrated this practice
I do not it's not in my um scope of
knowledge I just know what my experience
is here in New Hampshire yeah just to
would you believe
um lately there have been a lot of news
segments regarding this bill and how
it's very effective in many other states
so it has been implemented great thanks
thank you for
that
oh oh God it representative
um is this a I noticed that it came
through insurance I mean it's Health and
Human Services but here we're we are
considering how to pay
uh for an expansion and extensions of of
your particular
service is am I am I correct in that
assessment yes
do we have
um
estimates as to
um the financial uh how much it's going
to cost or if we pass no we do not
is this a study committee no is there is
a commission and study committee in here
to figure out sustainable funding but
this is a
um a procedure maybe Dr Brown would you
he'll describe it for you thank you very
much thank you for letting me go first
with that so thank you okay Alex Brown
well we wanted to explain the team
system
great thank you yeah thank you
and now you got three minutes
thank you chairman
my name is Dr Alex Brown and I'm here
today on behalf of the New Hampshire
Psychological Association in strong
support of Senate bill 85. this
statement is also endorsed by the
behavioral health advisory committee I'm
a licensed psychologist and during my 10
years in practice I've worked almost
entirely within the primary care setting
I see firsthand what it means when
patients cannot access appropriate
services and the downstream effects this
has on primary care and our emergency
departments
data from the CDC indicates that suicide
is among the top 10 leading causes of
death for granite Staters which
disproportionately impacts both I hate
to interrupt you but we've kind of got
that already okay for the testimony and
I know you want to read your testimony
we will put it in to the permanent
record the uh could you just focus on
helping him out understand what is
exactly yeah with this bill so this bill
is a uh this calls for us removing the
prior authorization
um which which impacts uh patient access
to the crisis Management Services that
is uh that are described in the bill
there's the three arms there is the um
the 988 crisis hotline which is sort of
well publicized
um and effective but the other two
Services
um the of the the three arms are the
um
receiving units as well as the mobile
crisis Outreach
yeah so why don't you talk about the
mobile crisis unit what what is that all
about so to help you understand so these
are Regional these are Regional centers
that are set up
um and they are non-hospital settings
where patients can be received and
stabilized and the mobile crisis units
are just that they are they are teams
that are that mobilize in response um on
demand
to Patient uh patient crises in the
communities they go to where they are in
their homes in their workplaces again
non-hospital settings wherever they're
holed up at that moment where the crisis
is correct yeah
okay
you got one minute to wrap up all right
thank you
um
well I would I think I would like to uh
I did submit the data I think uh that
that actually I think is really critical
to understanding the need for this
um I will just say that um I wanna for
the for the record I want to tell the
story of a patient that I'll call
Richard who has constant ideas of
killing himself he is unemployed and
relies on Hospital financial assistance
to address his complex Health needs in
the past two years Richard has presented
to the Ed no less than six times for
suicidal ideation and has been admitted
four of those times when there have been
not enough available beds on the
psychiatric service he has been managed
on the medical floors all during a
global pandemic when hospital beds have
been in short supply none of this is
uncommon it is in fact the state of
crisis in crisis Management in the state
of New Hampshire it is both excessively
expensive and it is clinically
ineffective in contrast mobile response
units and receiving centers have been
shown to both improve clinical outcomes
as well as health spending I strongly
urge this committee to support SB 85 we
urgently need to embrace alternative
models to fund preventative Services to
keep patients Like Richard out of our
swelling emergency departments
the problem with it with which has been
well publicized in this state and who
also deserve evidence-based options
beyond our overburdened Primary Care
Workforce for crisis stabilization this
is true I called Richard yesterday for a
scheduled Telehealth appointment and he
could not speak because he was getting
into an Uber on the way to the ER
nhpa applauds the inclusion of a study
commission to ensure sustainability of
an effective system for crisis services
including feedback from the patients and
providers perspectives as well as from
policy and economic perspectives this
work cannot wait and this bill must not
be retained thank you for your time
thank you
uh chair we're calling Holly Stevens oh
I'm sorry
uh thank you
um
does the requirement for
pre-authorization for mobile crisis
Services put patients in danger it does
thank you
nothing else is a delay it's a it's a
delay
it's a delay because it had the long how
long it might take yes thank you okay
all right Holly Stevens from Nami New
Hampshire
foreign
good afternoon
uh chairman hunt members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness we are a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy I
will try to be brief because I know that
we are between you guys and lunch I've
got some data in here that I'm not going
to go through you can read that I have
faith in you but I did just want to
highlight the reason you have this bill
which is the insurance provision on the
prior authorizations which you've heard
a little bit about
um
in keeping with parity requirements this
bill would prohibit insurance companies
from requiring prior authorizations for
emergency Mental Health Services when
provided within the Mental Health crisis
program which is the mobile crisis teams
um
if a person has a physical health
emergency there is no prior
authorization required for them to go to
the emergency room and receive emergency
medical care a mental health emergency
should be not not be treated any
differently if a person calls 988 or not
or the New Hampshire rapid response and
is determined that a mobile crisis team
response is appropriate there should not
be a prior authorization required before
the mobile team is deployed
as you've heard mobile crisis teams
dispatch to the community they can be
seen someone can be seen in their home
at Dunkin Donuts anywhere
and so when you look at this bill if
there was a prior authorization not only
does it delay treatment but it could end
up costing more because if somebody has
to have a prior authorization before a
mobile team comes out and sees them it's
easier to just go to the emergency room
because you know that if you go to the
emergency room there is no prior
authorization so in order to keep folks
out of the emergency rooms when they're
in crisis so they can be seen in the
community it's really important that
there is no prior authorization and it's
my understanding that as this bill came
out of the Senate that the insurers were
on board with this and they can speak
for themselves but I think they're
neutral and they may not be speaking so
that is my understanding and I will take
any questions that you have
okay representative Herbert but remember
you're delaying in the process here just
uh 15 seconds
um so the mobile unit uh
um makes it uh you don't have to have a
prior authorization if a mobile unit
shows up
that's what that's what exactly what
this bill would do it would eliminate
the prior authorization or prohibit a
prior authorization for a mobile unit to
go to somebody's house
didn't feel up
uh thank you during during a
psychological emergency does a delay in
care increase danger to the patient
absolutely
okay we're all set
thank you very much
all right chair calls on Ami valeros
licensed social worker
and please don't tell anything we've
already heard
say something new
I'll try not to
my name is Amy valeris I have a PhD in
MSW and a clinical license and social
work and I'm here to urge you to support
SB 85 I'm a social worker at a primary
care clinic in Concord and I can attest
to the Mental Health crisis in our
community Rising exponentially both in
number and intensity in the last three
years
research has shown that nearly half of
all people whose suicide have seen their
Primary Care office in the month before
this is a statistic that weighs quite
heavily on those of us in primary care
even one suicide has us spinning for
days in weeks and years and should have
could have would have if we could go
back and see what could we have done in
our roles differently
the truth is all the Education and
Training and validated Assessments in
the world cannot give us a secure sense
of whether somebody is stable enough or
safe enough to walk out the doors of our
Clinic
this is a heavy burden to bear and
speaks to the need for the Mental Health
crisis response to live both inside and
outside the walls of Health Care
available and easy to access in the
community where people live
it is of a men's Solace to know that
they have access to a simple number like
I am not exaggerating when I say it is
this number that allows us to sleep at
night and when we lose sleep because we
are worried about patients we burn out
and we leave health care and currently
that is a problem for all of us because
it when Healthcare is understaffed all
of our health care needs go unaddressed
it is not only addressing the needs of
people in a mental health crisis but
also addressing the overwhelming burnout
of men of health care workers please
support SB 85 so New Hampshire people
can continue to access crisis Services
thank you
I should see
so evidently I had a pile of cards here
grant that I didn't see so now we have
great bossy who's introducing it for
Senator Bradley thank you
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Grant bossy from
the New Hampshire Senate here to
introduce you to a bill you have already
been introduced to on behalf of Senator
Jeb Bradley the prime sponsor of Senate
bill 88. I will give you the about the
break for lunch edit and get through as
quickly as I can the first two sections
of this bill relate to the 988 Suicide
Prevention line based on uh Congress
passing the suicide hotline designation
Act of 2020. this helps Implement that
federal law here in the state of New
Hampshire
section 2 creates a definition of
Behavioral crisis programs which
includes a Continuum of Care based on
the three foundational principles of our
substance abuse 988 call centers mobile
crisis units and receiving facilities
section three of the bill creates a
study Commission on sustainable funding
of Behavioral crisis programs the last
two sections deal with adding mental
health or community-based Health crisis
intervention services into statute for
insurance coverage during the Senate HHS
hearing the committee heard extensive
testimony supporting the bill many of
whom spoke about the Mental Health
crisis in our state in the high rate of
suicide in New Hampshire thank you for
the opportunity to speak today I'll
defer questions to The Advocates if you
have any questions for Senator Bradley
I'll work to get you an answer other
than that I just thank you for your
consideration in support of Senate Bill
85. thank you
uh great so here's some homework
assignment for you representative
patusek thank you Mr chairman
um as the vice chair of the special
committee on commissions uh there isn't
a mission
in this bill there is no Sunset date
and uh is the first name Senator willing
to be the senator on this Commission
and I already know the answer because
that's Senator Bradley
he's taking notes
I appreciate that coach I know Senator
Bradley I will get those it is
nope because you know the commission
committee on commissions is trying to
reduce the number of commissions so if
there is a Sunset date that we're
looking for and obviously there is
because
uh
uh as I understand it on line 27 there
is a repeal on Section six that's a
sunset on the study commission it says
repeal look on the last line November
1st 2024. he says repeal that's a sunset
on here yes
actually take effect on passage don't
read the line before that yes yes I need
the line before that
the actual take effect no read the line
before that
does it say repeal does he see the word
repeal yeah
section six section six and then the
effective date of section six which is
repealing it is November 1st 2024. so it
has a one-year as a two-year life
okay it's not exceedingly clear to me
this is how we structure uh OLS
structures repeals uh when we ask them
to do them okay on the Senate side great
thank you very much thank you okay
Sabrina Dunlap am I reading this right
you have you guys have an amendment to
this or no you just what is this
scrolling you wrote about the support
neutral
are you studying to be a doctor
foreign
I thought you guys were neutral we are
thank you for the chance to speak
Sabrina Dunlap director of government
relations at Anthem I just wanted to
clarify a couple things we spoke when
this was in Senate HHS and at the time
had concerns around some definitions
that seemed vague the commission did not
include the insurance department or
anyone from ahip so that has been
amended
um and the amended version I think where
carriers are okay with because some of
the definitional vagueness went away I
just want to clarify that there is
currently no prior auth for emergency
services including mobile rapid response
so the amended version clarifies that
mental health emergencies are part of
the existing definition of emergency
services for which there is no prior off
so anyway I just wanted to clarify that
um and make it clear like I don't think
insurance is actually a barrier to these
Services currently but we support the
commission and
support rapid response mobile crisis
moving forward
fair enough thank you any questions from
the committee members
see none thank you very much
okay Ellen plum
do we already have her yes
and Emma savini from new Futures there
she is
and John okay
I get cards put in twice
okay
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
for having me be sure you pull the mic
close for the record my name is Emma
savini I am the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new Futures
new Futures is a
nonpartisan non-profit organization that
Advocates educates and collaborates for
the health and well-being of all Granite
Staters I'll keep it extremely brief we
are here in support of SP 85 we think
the study commission is necessary to
find a sustainable funding source for
these programs that you've heard how
important they are to our communities
many states Across the Nation right now
are dealing with the same issue and
dealing with it in different ways so
this study commission would just Loop in
the legislature to make sure that we
find a solution that works for New
Hampshire
secondly removing the pre-authorization
requirements just makes these Services
more accessible to people would help
reduce our strain on the emergency
departments and it's also an
evidence-based practice that has been
shown to be more cost effective I'm
happy to take any questions
I think they're ready for lunch thank
you okay one card left John dejoy New
Hampshire Psychological Association
and didn't check anything but I assume
you're in support of the bill
put a card in this time all right let's
see
getting better
I'm new here and you used to be a rep
that I remember
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is John dejoy
representing New Hampshire Psychological
Association as you heard from Dr Brown
and HPA fully supports SP 85 just to
want to make two points this bill and
the testimony around this bill you heard
from the uh the doctor as well as from
Dr Brown points out quite clearly the
need for Primary Care Behavioral Health
why we brought in Senate Bill 235 that
is now retained that we're still working
on with the insurance department and why
that bill is so important secondly one
of the in the commission there are no
clinicians on the commission I
understand it's a fiscal commission
primarily but you can't talk about
finances without understanding the
practice and we would ask that a member
of nhpa be added as a named member of
the commission with that I'll conclude
my remarks
foreign
an email on that yeah thanks okay
all right any other any questions from
the committee members
okay
we'll
see close to public hearing on uh Senate
bill I do have a I do have a question
for you Mr chairman okay
is the same committee for cannabis still
going to be the same members is the
liquor committee okay Liquor Division
yes
okay and uh so I will be discussing with
the commission uh what we've got here in
the hearing and seeing how we can figure
out some way to keep the atcs in it
because everybody seems to want to hug
an ATC this week
but I I have to be I'll be honest I
voted against atcs from right from the
get-go because to me that they were it
was the Campbell's nose Under the Tent
let alone the fact that if we were ever
to legalize marijuana how are we going
to deal with them and I knew this I
predicted this problem was going to
occur
cannot be administered
I have to be administered through
medicinal needs
uh
very special
right but that all you're doing is
arguing for what I would say is then why
can't leave the atcs alone just let them
stay alone but no they're convinced
they're going to put them out of
business because evidently the patients
don't seem to understand what you just
said
so with that we're done Dems are going
to lunch
Barley House
it's a free lunch
foreign